because the question is whether the dow
is overvalued here as it approaches
20,000 there's no question stocks are
not cheap where the SP which of course a
broader index although the dow is you
know reaching that milestone is selling
for about 20 21 times this year's
operating earnings and although i don't
think that that's out of line given the
interest rates interest rates are rising
i think we're going to get to 20 i think
we're going to close over 20 before
year-end but i think the path to 21,000
is going to be a little tougher it's
going to be show me show me the earnings
you know show me some of these good
things that you are promising before i
think we would really have another
strong rally and we would we went up on
the Dow ten percent in in just a matter
of six weeks and I don't think we're
gonna we're going to repeat that shortly
what measures are you placing most
confidence and if you take a look at my
Bloomberg you'll see that the dough you
know the relative strength index shows
that it's at the highest in 20 years
that's your 3505 if you look at the you
know schiller Cape ratio it's also
extremely high what are you looking at
to measure well I'm looking at I've
written on the show or measure that why
that might be overly bearish some work
on that I look at next year's earnings
and which I believe are too optimistic I
have toned them down but I think what
has driven this rally is the expectation
of significant corporate tax reform that
could in and of itself boost S&P
earnings by ten percent some even think
higher so I mean that explains the
movement of the Dow you know we get less
regulation if we get stronger
infrastructure that sends the economy
that's almost like frosting on the cake
that would send it higher but I think
the the real move is taxation with the
hope of less regulation and there and
that taxation legislation is moving wrap
through through Congress at this
particular point Jeremy I understand of
course that the bull market in stocks
you know has been driven further since
of course Donald Trump was elected now
what we've also seen is that rotation
out of the bond market Jeffrey Gundlach
said earlier this week that if a 10-year
treasury yield hits even three percent
next year the losses might actually
spread beyond bonds and into stocks and
real estate what I'm wondering is if
interest rates rise throughout the
economy could we actually see retail
investors start to pull out of the stock
market and what would that do to the
bull market well rising yields is
definitely a headwind and and certainly
the interest rate sensitive sectors and
we're talking about REITs in particular
some of the utilities are still going to
be challenged in in a rising interest
rate scenario but let's look at the big
picture I remember I guess I'm old
enough to remember when I thought three
percent was unbelievably low for the
Treasury yield so in the big picture I
don't see three percent challenging
stops I mean the dividend paying stocks
are almost paying three percent with you
know with growth inflation hedge
possibilities that I think make them so
attractive so yes from what we were used
to three percent looks high but from an
absolute standard it is still in my
opinion not a challenge for stocks
nonetheless I agree those that are yield
based are certainly going to be you know
more challenged and those the the
particularly the financials of course
raising interest rates is a very big
positive and that the financials I think
are almost half the rally we've had
since Trump has been elected